I do believe in diversifying for sure
but I'm not ready yet and I will
diversify I do have an exit strategy I
don't think you know crypto is going to
be the best thing forever I do think
Bitcoin will be but eventually I am
going to get out of Bitcoin eventually
I'll probably sell hopefully at the top
of the market please God I'm able to
time that well and go back in in the
bare Market but not going fully you know
I do want to buy properties I do want to
hold gold bars like I want all of it but
right now you know I'm only in my 20s so
right now like I'm still building I'm
still figuring it all out so right now
yeah my portfolio is 100% crypto